it's about these medical students who
are at the top of their class and
they're over jeepers and they tried
their best to do what they can but in
this day and age you can't just be a
doctor you have to invent something you
have to do something that sets you apart
what's going on
I would like you to stop my heart you
gave it one minute and then you bring me
back okay now is the point where you say
it's all a joke Courtney I play my own
page is this young woman who decides to
test the boundaries and figure out she's
very curious about what happens to a
person when they die and especially in
that period of time when people describe
the white light they decide to get
together after hours and medically kill
one another for two to four minutes
depending on who it was and monitor the
brain what to see what activity there is
and and then figure out the answer to
the white light mystery how is she
playing the piano now it's like her
brain's been rewired I'm going next
charging 200 I'm sure it's gonna be
scary at times
I'm sure there's gonna be a lot of
tension and awfully they'll be sitting
at the edge of their seats because so
many crazy things happen